the other big story which barely got
reported on is that the U.S dollar is
basically in free fall and we are
watching a complete realignment of the
world monetary policy uh here is Will
Kane from Fox News uh talking a bit
about the realignment that we're seeing
related to the dollar right now I'm
going to put an announce this week that
Russia will begin using the Chinese Yuan
uh to for international payments instead
of the dollar Saudi Arabia is also in
talks with Beijing to do the same thing
speaking of Saudi Arabia meanwhile they
are in talks uh with Iran as well to
consider an economic alliance with China
and Russia and they can even be joining
the bric countries which is an acronym
for these countries here Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa these
countries all have emerging economies
Jeffrey this is your department as an
economist
um this is not good it's almost as if
endlessly printing money based on
nothing here in the United States was
not only going to have problems for our
wallets but actually how countries treat
us and who they align with
uh yeah I would say that's that's right
the big problem for the US in terms of
the the the dollar is the international
Reserve currency concerns also it's
trade policies from 2018 to the present
I mean the U.S proved itself to be an
unreliable trading partner with with
random dictates so now we're going to
add five percent taxes under Goods now
there's a 10 now the 15 or 25 so what's
the basis for it oh it's the trade
deficit wait that's bad economics what
are you doing uh we've had more or less
you know consistently lower tariffs and
global trade since uh the end of World
War II and now we're just changing all
the rules so that's what Doom did and
then the attack on Russia the sanctions
on Russia and the confiscation of assets
of a dollar denominated was a way of
saying if you use the dollar we can we
can we can lock your accounts we can
steal from that was a terrible decision
so it was both both Trump's trade
policies and the by Administration
sanction Russia just made it inevitable
but now we look around the world and my
God you know Iran Brazil China Saudi
Arabia Russia you know everybody's
turning against it so you know how long
is this going to take before the dollar
is unseated as the international Reserve
currency I think it's going to be a
while but what matters here is the
trajectory and it it doesn't look good
and as you implied we've got other
problems with the dollar here at home uh
namely it's it's domestic value in terms
of goods and services the pce
came out the data came out the other day
it's the fed's favorite inflation
measure and the services side of it
showed the largest increase in 12 months
which suggests that the Federal Reserves
uh interest rate policies of forever
raising rates are not not actually
concrete inflation that the uh 6.5
trillion dollars that they printed over
two years after this covet thing began
you know has to become endemic 5.5
trillion of that went into the banks
which they used to buy long-term bonds
that turned out to be devalued once the
federal reserve's policy came along and
that's destabilize the financial and
banking system even while real median
wages for Americans are going
dramatically down and credit card debt
is going up and it's costing ever more
to service that so you know we've got a
candle burning both both ends and also
getting thinner you know at the same
time it really is a disaster for U.S uh
prosperity and influence around the
world if you like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell